the Joe Rogan experience because I don't
really think of it you know that you
know these sort of creative puzzles that
way I do you know what creative puzzle
would be like you know a movie or a TV
show or a documentary and you know I
could go on and but you okay well jay-z
asked me because I knew jay-z because he
was very obsessed with wanting to do the
soundtrack to a movie called American
Gangster which I produced great movie
love that movie did you oh great thanks
I liked that one a lot too but so and I
said as much you know as a as impressed
as I am with jay-z and his level of you
know mastery himself I said look we've
already done the entire score I mean you
can't do it it's been done
he said well like I feel a kinship to
Frank Lucas who was played by Denzel
Washington because it ends up being a
drug dealer like the biggest heroin
dealer in America at the time and head
of like his own mafia that he creates
and so anyway the bottom line is he
feels this kinship to him he wants to do
this he's very dedicated I say it's
already done as much as you know
superstar you are and how great you are
and he said look I will do a second
album I don't have to be the primary
album that's on the screen I'll do a
second album and I said well I only have
three weeks he goes I will do the whole
thing in three weeks and he did it whoa
and I went and saw him he did the
singing he did the writing he did he
engineered it he did every single thing
so the guy is the king of hip-hop he
goes to work and I was really blown away
because he still you know had he has
that grit in him and and it turned out
to be like for real hip-hop lovers they
really liked this album I guess it was
everybody loves everything he does
though jay-z put out something that was
[ __ ]
he doesn't really yeah he's kind of
brilliant actually
he's a yeah it isn't he's a brilliant
marketer
he's when he said he says things that
are very insightful so he wanted to do
he's after that he we got to know each
other and then he said hey I'm gonna do
I'm gonna I want to do a festival a
festival with 24 22 different artists
and all different types and this could
be a love park and it's called we're
calling it made in America would you
produce it and and I said yeah and I
knew that Ron Howard could get a chance
at directing it and I thought it would
be really good for Rhonda me around
jay-z that's a good thing for him it's a
good he's got a good aura and the right
one for Ron and I thought well so we
joined him I said what is this about you
know what's the premise and he said it's
about democratization of music itself
there's no record stores anymore and and
the walls are down you could you know
you can get you know there's the
crossover between hip hop and yeah you
know trance music and all that stuff so
and I thought that was kind of cool and
then I said if you ever seen this movie
called because it didn't have a story
that this concert you ever see Amadeus
he goes I never seen Amadeus and I said
well it's about genius and he asked
about it he goes that's what the premise
of this will be and he immediately
thought had this idea that it should be
every artist every human being has a
little bit of genius in them and he made
it very relatable and that became the
thesis of what this documentary became
and he only had that like a week before
we were shooting so it was kind of
remarkable that's pretty remarkable
[Applause]